[Music]
meow
i don't know if like
you guys didn't hear about this but it's
not as widely publicized as i thought it
would be greenwood indiana about maybe
less than a week ago there was a mass
shooter that entered the mall oh god and
he got stopped yeah he got stopped who
stopped i wonder why they're not
reporting i know i know so he started
shooting people
this guy was armed like two rifles uh
overachiever dude a couple of other guns
two rifles damn that's a lot of guys
dumb he's not even tactically
intelligent yeah yeah
random bystander named elisha dicken
he's 22
saw it go down he
had a licensed uh to kill and carry
license to kill yes he was james bond
thanks for blowing his cover yeah so
he's got this handgun and um within 15
seconds 40 yards away takes out the wow
40 yards 40 years james bond bro good
man wow so the masher did actually uh
kill three other people but before
before uh he could cause even more
terror he got taken out by this dude wow
why do you think they don't report this
well i mean it is on the news that's how
you got it like like math but then look
like you guys didn't really no i have no
[ __ ] clue it's not part of the
narrative dude that kind of sucks that
he got killed by a guy named elijah
dicken
what a [ __ ] loser
that's the biggest roast ever what a
[ __ ] cup this guy right before he
died what's your name elijah dicken
yeah but i mean just the name alone it
should be publicized like how far is it
most pistol ranges are like 15 yards oh
[ __ ] this guy actually trains if you hit
him 40 yards with the and it's a moving
target yeah because if this i'm assuming
this guy's moving around that shit's
[ __ ] even harder yeah 40 yards he
actually trains for sure that's amazing
because i think i read about it where he
uh
i think he shot 10 rounds and eight of
them went into the guy's body wow
80 yeah he's a good shot it says that he
like he stabled himself against the pole
and then just like boom boom boom it's
like the other two shots hit the other
two people that died oh no
and then after he killed him he just
started dragging him towards him with
the whole
so you can see his work
he's like pretty good shot take his
goggles off
damn that's a tight ass scene if he like
shot him and then the guy stumbles into
like a dry cleaner
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
terrible
yeah so he had a license to carry the
handgun but i guess in indiana you don't
even need it
it says dicken did not need the license
because constitutional or permit-less
carry became law
on july first oh yeah some states have
constitutional care arizona has it what
uh what defines constitutional carry
specific so constitutional carry just
means like the way that when the
constitution was written that they
anybody can carry any way that they want
so you can [ __ ] wear it as a hat or
as a [ __ ] parrot like any way you
want you could be underneath your
clothes
this is pistol parrot
say hello
it's up to your own discretion you know
mm-hmm thank you for explaining what
that pistol parent was going off
they explained way better than you dude
you only two nine you cannot shoot me
you have no accents man i want to talk
like that from now on dude
the constitution
would you like some artist julius
when they made the constitution yes they
did
would you please stand 40 yards away
i'm used to it
is there any orange julius left ever
like yeah where i need to go to one now
i saw one at the oc fair what is that
wait that's a booth it's like um
you heard a dairy queen so dairy queen
used to be paired sometimes with like
orange julius the way that carl's had
green burrito and it would be like
creamsicle like orange sherbet it was
the jamba juice before jamba juice wow
you say sherbet very good ryan oh what
is it it's not sorbet is it sherbert wow
the fact that he even went there what's
the difference between sorbet and sure
phonetically written as sherbet most
people pronouncing it as sherbert what
are you talking about get the [ __ ] out
of here look at that [ __ ] up right now
what's gonna happen now sure hey what
the [ __ ] are you doing let him google it
let him google no i don't know how to
type
is this sorbet and sherbert the same
[ __ ] s-h-e-r-b-e i don't think so i
think sorbet is water-based yeah
water-based ice cream all right here it
is i'm gonna play the i'm gonna play the
phonetic sherman
sure german sherbet but it's spelt
sherbert
sherbet i thought you said it was spelt
sherbet
i say sherbert yeah i'm number one for
so long that's some european [ __ ] we now
must duel yeah so what's the difference
10 paces that way 40 yards yeah yeah and
from what oh no the drill
is the one with orange
it's different it's like a mixture of it
yeah it's a rainbow rainbow ice cream
sorbets are the [ __ ] though
so is sorbet like the more like icy it's
fruity and icing okay and then sorbet is
like a no non-dairy
um
pop i feel like sherbet has dairy no
it's water-based i think that's sorbet
oh sorbet sherbet is with milk by the
way it should be noted that all three
victims that died were latino
why the [ __ ] would you look at me how do
you feel i think it's because you're
latinx
however
however
we'll survive we'll do there's a lot of
you guys we will reproduce
we will reproduce we'll be back where
was it at again what mall greenwood
india and do we know them what are we
doing in indiana huh it might be the
puerto rican side dude that's what
mexican people do
they don't know if it was targeted to a
specific like race or anything they just
know that he strapped up went in there
you start going crazy yeah that's crazy
he didn't have like a manifesto
imagine the guy who saved him had a
personal manifesto a constitutional one
oh
this [ __ ] check makes his ass that'll
be sick as [ __ ] i'm glad he [ __ ] took
him down
anybody else that's [ __ ] jesus it was
like a really cute video too of like i
guess they were in he didn't do any of
his own thing but they talked to his
grandmother the uh the good samaritan
guy yeah and um she was just like oh
well you know like he's not he's not
particularly like he's not as fast as me
but
killed a man yeah she was like it really
does a lot to you and you have to take
someone's life so everyone please please
pray for him it's like so cute
or the [ __ ]
do you feel like if i taught him
everything i know
she has a musket though because he's
he's not like a written house like type
you know he wouldn't be like
well when i shoot people i pack it
through the muzzle for three minutes
and there's a drummer is it the joy
the [ __ ] trumpet boy has to be
[Laughter]
that's why the old [ __ ] movies like
those civil war movies cracked me the
[ __ ] up dude you know it was way slower
than that
last of the mohicans it's exactly that
it's the worst i love it when they're
doing that while their friend is getting
like a cannonball blown off their head
and they're like
why were we losing to the native
americans because they were just doing
this all day
there's getting murked
behind a tree too
i was gonna ask do you uh feel like if
people
all constitutionally or whatever carried
guns there would be
less there's a lot of people i uh don't
want to [ __ ] have fun it needs to be
a
multi-faceted thing
so for example
if uh let's say it was constitutional
carry and also we were like korea where
all dudes go to the military it's
different then everyone's trained to the
same level and we have everyone has a
different level of understanding in
america you have some people that view
guns as if it's a fishing rod it's just
a tool and i mastered it i could clean
it and open it recognize with my eyes
closed then there's someone else that
looks at it as if it's this radioactive
glowing thing that i don't even like i'm
scared to even touch so that's the hard
part where you're not having people at
the same like
mental mind state uh approaching the
same tool
you know what i mean yeah i understand
but maybe that's because it's like um so
you know not everybody is either capable
like the states have different views on
it there are different restrictions of
laws
i think my question is based off of like
if i hypothetically was like a mass
shooter but i knew everybody else was
carrying a gun you'd think twice
you know going in and trying to match
shoes all right [ __ ] yeah you would go
to a gun free zone because you're like
you know what no one's going to have
guns here
yeah yeah if i need victims specifically
you're going to go to a gunfight this
this guy's not going on a military base
to do mass shootings exactly just like
how like like people that want to start
fights with [ __ ] they go to a
bar they're not going to jail yeah
they'll go to jiu jitsu school yeah oh
i'ma [ __ ] some fools up and go to
[ __ ] like a mma school they go to a
place where like chinese people used to
do that and was sick yeah that's true my
style is better than yours yeah yeah we
gotta bring that back that's if that's
what bombers thought too i can't bomb
this place everyone else has got bumps
too
the lowest
he's like what if everybody's got one of
these chicks
oh that's really bad we're all gonna
[ __ ] experience the bomb free zone
imagine you could still carry grenades
okay hey put that grenade i'm gonna blow
you up too
oh yeah wherever we're all dying you
know you know our uh our buddy vince so
vince used to shoot for me he's also a
pretty well known people what kind of
shooting what kind of shooting so his
dad looking insanity yeah
so his dad actually looks like a very
notorious uh [ __ ] uh japanese
unibomber and so
he was like on the time magazine his dad
looks like his identical two he looks
like a the that cult leader that gas the
whole train network no it's um i forgot
his name but the he has a beard yeah
yeah so his dad looks exactly like him
so his dad got arrested because they
thought they caught the [ __ ] universe
oh that's so
[ __ ] hilarious dude
that's another level of doppelganger
suckiness he was a leader of a cult
terrorist group not his dad but he
looked he's a look-alike to him and then
they gassed a bunch of people in japan
in the train system oh i remember that
is that guy still on the loose or
something is that why they [ __ ]
arrested vince's dad well they he just
looks exactly like him he even dresses
the same they already caught him but
they just needed to catch the look-alike
we got to be sure we gotta dip it in the
bud
[Music]
you